"Construye un triángulo equilátero inscrito dentro
del círculo." Permíteme dibujar otro círculo que
tenga exactamente las mismas dimensiones que
el círculo original. Este se ve bastante bien.
Y ahora permíteme mover este centro para que
se quede sobre la circunferencia del original;
así que ahora el centro de cada uno está sobre la
circunferencia del otro. Ahora pensemos en algo:
si dibujamos este segmento justo aquí, que por
supuesto tiene la longitud del radio, y luego
dibujamos otro segmento, ponemos un extremo en
el centro del nuevo círculo y el otro extremo
lo ponemos encima de la circunferencia del círculo
anterior, este segmento sigue teniendo la longitud
del radio de ambos círculos, así que estos dos
segmentos tienen la misma longitud. Y si ahora
usamos otro segmento para conectar este punto
con este punto, seguirá midiendo lo mismo que
el radio de nuestro círculo original, y también
tendrá la misma longitud que estos dos, así que
con estos tres segmentos construimos un triángulo
equilátero. Ahora bien, ¿para qué nos sirve esto?
Bueno, sabemos que los ángulos internos de
un triángulo equilátero miden 60°, así que
este ángulo mide 60°, ¿y qué tiene de interesante
que sean 60°? Bueno, imagina que construimos otro
triángulo aquí, de forma simétrica, pero reflejado
hacia abajo, siguiendo el mismo argumento este
ángulo justo aquí entre estos dos lados también va
a ser de 60°, así que todo este ángulo interior,
si sumamos estos dos, medirá 120°. Ahora, ¿por
qué nos interesa esto? Bueno, si este ángulo
interior es de 120° eso significa que este arco
de aquí mide 120° o, lo que es lo mismo, mide
1/3 de la vuelta alrededor del triángulo, ya que
eso es 1/3 de la vuelta alrededor del triángulo,
si tuviera que conectar estos dos puntos, ahora
este sería un lado de nuestro triángulo equilátero
esto de aquí es la secante de un arco que mide
una tercera parte del círculo completo. Y ahora
puedo usar esto para ilustrar otras cosas. Voy
a reutilizar esto, voy a mover este círculo
alrededor del otro círculo y una vez más sólo
quiero intersecar estos dos puntos. Ahora puedo
tomar uno de estos, ponerlo por acá, tomo el otro
y lo pongo por acá, y uso exactamente el mismo
argumento. Puedo decir que este arco mide 120°,
por lo que puedo afirmar que éste será un lado
de nuestro triángulo equilátero, es la secante de
un arco de 120°. Y ahora sólo me queda conectar
estos dos últimos puntos y listo, terminamos.
Hemos construido nuestro triángulo equilátero.